president Trump's former right-hand man
says things in the West Wing were 50
times what you've heard and his former
chief strategist is still not telling
lawmakers what they want to hear but he
is talking to Special Counsel Robert
Muller chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge has new details on
that tonight Catherine well thank you
read a source close to the matter
confirms to Fox News that the former
White House chief strategist was
interviewed by the special counsel this
week Steve Bannon also testified behind
closed doors today in front of the House
Intelligence Committee committee members
voiced frustration after Bannon invoked
executive privilege on behalf of
President Trump there were 25 questions
that the White House authorized him to
answer he answered each of those he
would not go beyond those questions in
any of his answers and that's
frustrating to those Russell Kimmi so we
have a further steps to take and we will
be taking those Fox News confirms that
late last night White House Counsel Don
began sent a letter to Capitol Hill
explaining why executive privilege
covers the transition that was not
enough for the committee's ranking
Democrat who claims bandhans in contempt
and his privileged claim is overly broad
and unsustainable we cannot permit a
situation where the White House is
allowed to script self-serving and
misleading questions that's where the
Democrats counter memo about alleged
surveillance abuses and when it will be
public the congressman had no comment as
he walked away from reporters Brett and
Gavin what are we learning from this new
interview from the former White House
chief of staff well in the wide-ranging
interview published by Vanity Fair
former White House chief of staff
Reince Priebus describes a president who
was afraid of no one the media insanity
and the behind-the-scenes drama quote
take everything you've heard Priebus
said and multiply it by 50 an FBI
director James Comey Priebus says he
knew the may 2017 firing would be a
political mistake as they watched the
nonstop media coverage unfold
benen apparently exploded with anger
quote there's not an effing thing you
can do to sell this ban and shout it at
the president's son-in-law Jared Kushner
nobody can sell this PT Barnum couldn't
sell this Priebus also reports President
Trump dressed down Attorney General Jeff
Sessions blaming his recusal for the
Special Counsel appointment
Priebus describes a dramatic chain of
events where he ran down to the West
Wing parking lot got in sessions black
sedan and urged him not to quit quote I
dragged him back up to my office from
the car the Vice President Mike Pence
and Bannon came in and we started
talking to him to the point where he
decided that he would not resign right
then Justice Department today had no
comment on the allegations Brett okay
captain thank you